a recently approved medication for
alzheimer's disease making headlines due
to its price tag 56 000 a year heather
mills talked to a brain health
researcher over at unlv who says this
medication is just the beginning of some
big advances in medicine
47 000 nevadans have alzheimer's disease
it's the sixth leading cause of death in
the nation we're really dealing with a
disease that we have to respond to until
this summer it had been nearly 20 years
since the fda last approved a medication
to fight this epidemic now some promise
the pharmaceutical industry invested
42.5
billion dollars
to get that was the investment from 1995
to the time adu helm was approved the
drug which is given intravenously
activates the brain's immune system to
remove abnormal protein buildup but it
comes at a price 56 000 a year per
person dr jeffrey cummings a research
professor with unlv's department of
brain health says it's not unusual to
see that initially that's a high price
it is very similar to what
people are paying for cancer drugs right
now atta helm only slows the progression
of mild impairment but dr cummings says
this is just the beginning right now we
have to use scanning
to diagnose the proper patient well it
looks like we're going to be able to do
that with blood tests very soon that's
another reason he speculates the price
of attalhelm will eventually go down
there are these other drugs that look
like they're working as well two of them
have already been submitted to the fda
and you know competition is going to
force that price down we feel like we've
turned the corner that we have we're in
a whole new era of alzheimer's disease
heather mills live local now